marion sortie en avant première du film
wall trade center de oliver stone avec
nicholas cage dans le rôle principal le
film raconte l'histoire vraie de deux
policiers piégés dans les tours lors des
attentats du 11-septembre compte rendu
martine laroche-joubert et pascal
chaufferie le world trade center
aujourd'hui le vide à la place des tours
jumelles en 2011 une autre tour la plus
haute du monde voit les remplacer les
elle n'effacera pas leur mémoire
presque cinq ans après la tragédie le
premier grand film hollywoodien sort sur
les écrans américains
un drame basé sur une histoire vraie
celle de deux filles new yorkais en
service ce jour-là
pour la première à new york de ce film
de oliver stone moins d'invités
prestigieux que d'habitude sur le tapis
rouge
mais les sauveteurs du 11 septembre et
leurs familles
l'histoire est vécue à l'intérieur d'une
patrouille de volontaires de la police
en charge des secours
les vrais héros sont là j'ai vérifié que
les détails et est vrai avec toute
l'équipe
ça nous a aidés parce que nous avons
besoin de nous détacher de ce qui s'est
passé ce jour là c'était trop dur était
l'un des deux filles confie sous les
décombres et retrouver par miracle ou
plus de 12 heures après la star nicolas
cage à côté de son modèle ce film montre
que l'on peut survivre c'est ça c'est
très réconfortant fort c'est un film de
coeur je vois je j'ai pleuré moi même
j'ai vu avec beaucoup de gens au monde
déjà je sais que ça marche pour les gens
qu'ils ont du coeur
au-delà des polémiques qui agitent
actuellement les états unis sur des
défaillances de surveillance militaire à
l'époque
oliver stone lui a choisi le parti du
courage des hommes sur le terrain là il
n'y a pas de doute
21 02